long before there were digital downloads
this is how you made an album and
rainbow records the recipe hasn't
changed from the baths plating nickel on
discs to the vinyl pellets melted down
into gooey bubblegum it's the process of
heating up the dye the hot vinyl and
hydraulic pressure goes under about
1,800 pounds just please it out kind of
like make a waffle we're inside one of
just a dozen facilities in North America
still pressing records just four years
ago rainbow records was down to
producing only 5,000 LP use a day but
now for our average day of about 22 to
25 thousand records a day you're
producing upwards of 25,000 records here
a day six days a week last year six
million LPS were sold in the US small
versus total album sales but that's 144
percent growth in four years compare
that to fifty four percent growth for
digital albums and a forty four percent
drop in CD sales if you want to know why
vinyls hot look no further than rap
artist Macklin weighs 10,000 a year and
a half after the release of his hit
album The Heist rainbows busy
manufacturing the vinyl version and
there's a digital twist when you buy the
physical today in certain cases like
this one they'll give you the digital
copy as well right right that's very
common to broaden its reach McLemore
made the LP available at retailers like
Whole Foods and Urban Outfitters where
it quickly sold out inspire
entertainment distributes vinyl to
retail stores they're not only selling
those units but they've got a 12 inch by
12 inch picture of themselves in a store
that that speaks to their brand with
music fans feeling nostalgic about the
album art and packaging rainbows
scrambling to meet the new demand for
vinyl with old equipment its newest
record press is 35 years old and album
testing takes place on a vintage
turntable this is actually a CD
centering machine that
converted for vinyl this is a CD machine
that was converted for vinyl that kind
of tells you where we're going